nous accueillons aujourd'hui noël ou
chaîne miss québec 2020 le concours de
personnalités qui ont intérêt à préciser
qui fait rêver beaucoup de jeunes filles
ici au québec et au canada et ailleurs
bonjour les oiseaux chantent bonjour
alors la motion c'est un rêve de petite
fille qui se réalise avec cette couronne
de miss québec 2020 c'est pas tellement
un petit si j'ai envie de dire parce que
c'était pas mes objectifs en arrivant
ici au québec au tout début mais c'est
quand même un but que je me suis fixé à
partir du moment où je me suis engagé
avec eux la seule organise donc en
arrivant au québec en tant qu'étudiante
il ya cinq ans il n'y avait pas
d'objectif
y'avait pas dans vos valises le plan
miss québec languit tout ça faisait pas
partie de mes plans n'importe où et
comment s'est passé le concours
comment ça s'est passé est ce que c'est
une soirée est ce que c'est puisque vous
dites que ces deux basés sur la
personnalité nous habituellement miské
bac ou bien me smith n'importe quel pays
c'est le défilé en bikini c'est on nous
parle pas de personnalité alors oui dans
le monde entier en général pas que ni au
canada ni au québec et a beaucoup de
concours de beauté qui disent que c'est
aussi des concours de personnalités mais
en effet à beaucoup beaucoup de défilés
en maillot de bain il ya beaucoup de
défilés tout court alors que pour notre
cas ça c'est pas du tout passé comme ça
c'était vraiment basé sur la
personnalité
durant les neuf mois on a fait beaucoup
d'activités avec toutes les filles
réunies durant lesquels on a pu être
observées ainsi que pendant les gars là
bien sûr où les juges nous attribuer des
notes relatives à notre attitude notre
manière de parler de notre aisance sur
scène et notre sourire mais c'était pas
du tout un critère le physique mais vous
n'allez pas me dire que c'est un
concours géniaux renard comme c'est la
beauté elle est importante dans ce
concours ce n'est pas un point tabou
j'imagine on sait pas du tout en pointe
à bouder toutes les filles qui
participent sont très belles
seulement qu'on soit moins grosse moins
mince minces ou rondes ou plus petit
c'est pas du tout un critère sur lequel
on se bat pour élire la miss est ce
qu'on vous pose cette question
particulière
comment est ce qu'il ya des questions
quand vous surprend par des questions
sur votre culture générale sur ce que
l'on me pose des questions en
mathématiques excusez moi je me pose
cette question nous a pas vraiment de
questions mathématiques il s'est
beaucoup des questions qui servent à
voir notre manière de penser qu'ils
servent à aller un peu chercher ce qu'on
pense c'est souvent des questions liées
à l'actualité ou encore à des à des
phénomènes sociaux récents ou bien ou
bien encore d'actualité mais il n'y a
pas vraiment de test de culture générale
c'est vraiment des questions soit qu'on
connaît au préalable soit des questions
comme à la finale qu'on nous pose sur
place donc qu'on connaissait pas avant
et coca long de répondre parce que je
vous demande et c'était quoi la question
quand vous a posé en finale les
questions que vous vous posez à la
finale celle que je connaissais donc
avant c'était je devais un peu de
débattre sur le fait que l'éducation
soit une arme ou pas dans la société
ma réponse évidemment cette et oui et
gervais volonté et la question surprise
donc classe permis de départager des six
fils des six finalistes
c'était à quels problèmes observés vous
dans notre société et comment
feriez-vous pour y remédier parfaite
donc vraiment là vous avez été pris par
surprise et là vous avez convaincu le
jury et hoëdic mans ne pensez vous pas
que ce genre de concours puisse mettre
la pression surtout d'un point de vue de
beauté sur les filles qui sont pas dans
la norme je mets entre guillemets la
norme
je mesure bien ce que je dis non pas du
tout c'est pas du tout en moins de
pression c'est au contraire un concours
qui est fait pour booster en quelque
sorte la confiance en soi défie toutes
les filles peuvent participer ya pas de
critères pour défis qui sont je vais
employer le mot - dans les normes qui
ont qui sont dictées par les concours
parce qu'en réalité a pas de norme mais
c'est vraiment un concours accessible à
toutes les filles âgées entre puisqu'il
ya plusieurs catégories donc ces ag
entre eux
étaient ils semblent ou 30 ans est pas
basé sur le physique on compte
uniquement vous compte que vous avez
vous avez croisé ce concours j'imagine
ce serait sur internet le don d'une
publicité reste que vous avez hésité
parce qu'en ce moment on trouve que les
jeunes filles sont assaillis de partout
et les propositions ne sont pas toujours
claires et parfois c'est louche quand
proposition confère aux jeunes filles
surtout content un bon un physique une
beauté évidente
est ce que pour vous ça a été facile de
vous n'avez pas hésité dès le départ
alors non j'ai beaucoup hésité
au début j'ai beaucoup hésité parce qu'à
mon arrivée ici au canada j'ai été aussi
abordés par plusieurs agences de
mannequins par plusieurs photographes
par plusieurs sortes de boîtes qui
embauche un peu défis et qu'il est
rémunéré pour faire des shootings photos
c'était pas tous bourse et des offres
que j'avais refusé à l'époque ça
paraissait toujours très bizarre on
avait toujours après moi je me dis que
des offres comme ça qui sont assez
mystérieuse on peut vite leurs marques
et pour miss québec j'étais au début
hésitant après il faut savoir que avec
miss québec on mettrait bien encadrer
les personnes qui sont mineurs sont
toujours accompagnés de leurs parents y
a rien qui se fait dans le vide ou qui
se fait vraiment au hasard c'est
vraiment on est encadré
et quand j'ai vu un peu comment ça se
déroule et quand on est venu donc chez
moi pour me faire signer mon contrat
j'ai pu j'ai pu vraiment voir avant de
m'engager et aussi avoir du recul pour
pour être en mesure d'accepter
finalement vous avez des biscuits 2020
dites moi il me ce québec ckoi ses
engagements pendant l'année où elle a
sept couronnes dans l'année où on a sept
couronnes en fait il n'ya pas vraiment
d'engagements réels qu'on nous dit que
c'est vraiment chacune comment elle le
prend après c'est sûr que notre but à
tous temps j'imagine moi on sait que
l'ennemi sans terreur et eleni sculpture
ça serait vraiment de prouver que les
flippers confiance en elles quelles que
soient leurs leur tour de taille ou
quelles que soient leurs tailles de
vêtements
c'est vraiment
on veut apprendre aux filles à avoir
confiance en elle à se respecter à
s'entraider
c'est vraiment les valeurs auxquelles on
tient et vous miss québec 2020 vous noël
ou gérard vives ou une cause
particulière qui vous tient à coeur
moi personnellement oui j'ai plusieurs
causes qui me tient à coeur et parmi ces
causes ya vraiment des causes qui rentre
dans ce contexte là des muscles et bex
est vraiment prévenir on sait que le
taux de suicide est très très élevé chez
les jeunes de notre âge depuis plusieurs
années surtout depuis les années 2000
donc moi ça serait vraiment un peu de
prévenir ce taux parce que de prévenir
ce phénomène pardon parce que quand on
apprend que des filles peuvent se
suicider soit parce qu'elles sont
rabaissées soit parce qu'elles n'ont pas
confiance en elle physiquement ça
sachant que moi personnellement ça me
choque et on remarque conditions afin
qu'il ya aussi plein timide à sion
contre les jeunes filles est-ce que ce
qu'une miss québec où vous avez est-ce
que vous avez des accents envers ses
filles ou bien de la sensibilisation
c'est sûr que nous on est on est très
proches les unes des autres
donc on est moins présente ses très
proches des candidates pour miss québec
2021 donc on discute beaucoup
l'émission intérieur aux cimes donc
c'est sûr qu'on discute entre nous on
encourage à chacune et puis après des
d'intimidation sur des réseaux ça arrive
tout le temps à tout le moins aux
événements réels j'en ai reçu beaucoup
des messages très on va dire des traits
soir à bessan soit des messages méchants
si je peux dire mais au début ça nous
touche parce que ça serait mentir de
dire que ça ne touche pas au début ça ne
touche comme tout le monde on se sont
pas trop bien les habits de saab ont
ensemble on en pleure pas non plus mais
à fur et à mesure qu'on les vit
aujourd'hui c'est l'emploi et pour vous
donc fort donc mission vous allez être
exposés certainement donc vous êtes
prête à affronter ça vous avez vos
techniques
est ce que ces techniques là vous allez
les les donner aux autres jeunes filles
pour affronter ce phénomène là et bien
sûr et qu'on ait préparé quand on est
ministre on est comme j'étais on est
vraiment bien encadrés par l'organisme
on est très soutenue
à différentes choses qu'on peut vivre
après on fait avec et puis même quand on
n'est pas miss a beaucoup de gens qui
les vivent
et pour les futurs mais c'est bien sûr
que je serai là pour elle et que je leur
ferai partager un peu mon expérience
pour elle qu'elle puisse en sortir ans
est pour vous la vie après miss québec
ce serait quoi la vie après miss québec
ça serait déjà toujours d'être autant
impliqué dans l'organisme donc plus en
tant que ministre mais mais sûrement je
vais encore compliquer davantage parce
que c'est vraiment une expérience malgré
la situation c'est vraiment une
expérience qui va rester un mémorable
pour moi et bien évidemment je peux pas
je veux pas dire que c'est officiel mais
éventuellement les projets d'une miss
québec je dis pas pour moi mais c'est de
participer à miss canada hockey ce qu'on
vous souhaite beaucoup de chance je vous
remercie beaucoup en aval au chan pour
votre participation d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
je rappelle que vous êtes miss québec
2020 merci beaucoup c'est un beau passé
une réunion